welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's bought
and paid for and this video we're
breaking down the new trailer for the
boys season three it's filled with some
major plot details easter eggs and
things to look forward to when the show
releases in june throughout this video
we're going to be going over it all and
full spoilers ahead for the breakdown
there's a big thing from the comics i
think we could be leading too but i'll
give you another warning just before we
hit that without the way thanks for
clicking this now let's get into the
boys season 3.
okay so the last trailer gave away a lot
of hints towards where things could be
going and we know that soldier boy will
be playing a major part in the season
played by jensen ackles soldier boy in
the comics basically had the captain
america backstory and he was listed as
being the first superhero even though
stormfront actually was in the source
material there were several versions of
the character and the first one died in
world war ii and then the mantle was
passed to someone else before a third
soldier boy was brought in who was the
main one that popped up in the run in
the comics he was sleeping with
homelander at one point and it's gonna
be interesting to see if they adapt this
for the show or if they keep them as
rivals according to the creative team
soldier boy is gonna be way worse than
homelander and i think we're gonna see
him attempting to take the position of
the seven leader from the blue boy scout
well he's not really a boy scout is he
he's a bit of a bell end
now from the way the trailer is set up
it makes it seem like queen maeve goes
to berchie with both info on him and
also the compound v that we'll talk
about later on we get a scene in which
it's revealed that the boys end up being
the ones who discover his container at
the end of the new look which kind of
contradicts some of the earlier theories
i had though he's very much based on
captain america i have got a lot of
winter soldier vibes from him especially
due to his quote-unquote and thoring
that there seems to be due to the
missions that we see him in and the fact
he's contained i don't actually think
that would have brought him out in order
to negate the negative effects of
stormfront i actually think that he got
wrapped up in a lot of bad things and
that they ended up jailing him at one
point we see his record flash on screen
for a brief second and this says that he
was involved in racketeering with the
new england la cosa nostra the costa
nostra is what members of the mafia
refer to themselves as so it seems like
he got in bed with gangsters it's also
possible that he went crazy on a mission
and that could be the flashbacks that we
see him popping up in it looks like his
powers are way beyond what captain
america has and who knows he might have
been taking enhanced compound v we do
see him firing concursive blasts from
his chest almost like havoc from the
x-men which makes me think that he has
taken something else now this happens
when he's out in the street and also at
the end of the teaser kind of think he
might have stepped outside the lines of
what was expected of him and vultures
did whatever they could do in order to
cover it up there were newspaper
clippings in the first teaser that
referred to him as a fallen soldier so
what may affect his death which would
follow the same sort of lines as steve
rogers a stormfront was revealed to be a
nazi at the end of season 2 and like i
said i think that may reveals this to
butcher to blow the whole conspiracy
wide open i did think initially that
he'd be brought out in order for vote to
show they still have american ideals but
after this teaser yeah i'm completely
casting those theories to the side
homelander pretty much shows those
ideals themselves so it just seems
stupid that they bring out soldier boy
in order to basically do the same thing
with him now in the background we can
hear the song heroes and villains by the
beach boys and i love how this trailer
sort of blurs the lines between that you
have butchie being questioned over
whether he's turning into the thing he
hates and the potentially recruiting
older soups in order to push this idea a
line between heroes and villains is
blurred and it makes for a great teaser
so let me say it again cam i may be a
superhero but i'm also just a man who
fell in love with the wrong woman just
the man who fell for the wrong woman
for the wrong woman
i am very excited for everyone to meet
the real me now we open with homelander
on a pr circuit trying to spin
everything about his and stormfront's
relationship he appears on the cameron
coulson show the host of the vote news
videos that have been dropping on
youtube to discuss the characters at
length this whole thing just shows how
scripted these kind of moves are i love
how you have stan edgar looking at him
sternly from the corner of the dawn of
the seven premiere dawn of the seven is
the batman v superman parody we saw last
season and i really hope we get some
glimpses at the finished product
homelander says he's excited for people
to meet the real him and he's definitely
gone up the deep end in the comics he
ended up getting blackmailed by a
mysterious party that showed him doing
horrendous deeds and it won't spoil here
and this might end up being brought to
the show slowly this sent him more and
more insane and he just started
murdering everyone and doing what he
wanted starlight says he's lost his mind
and we catch him milking cows like i've
been milking doctor strange videos we
also see him tenderly looking over a
pool of blood on a hospital bed and it
might be that this belongs to stormfront
she was badly messed up last season so i
think they're kind of showing that he
still loves her even though the pr
stunts say differently
hey
we've been on the straight and narrow
all year
i'm killing soups no drinking
even follow hugh campbell's orders
without strangling him
now you're just being cruel or maybe
you're not such an [ __ ] now after the
cuts of him in the mirror we jump to
butcher who's apparently been on the
straight and narrow apparently allegedly
he goes out to meet ryan who's now out
in the wilderness still under the
protection of the cia and mallory he's
clearly still hacked off though and we
see him throwing darts with union jacks
on them this has a bulldog head on them
and this is not only a nod to him being
a british bulldog but also his actual
bulldog terror now the last time we saw
huey at the end of season 2 was when he
was joining victoria newman's campaign
trail at the end of the second season it
was revealed that she was of all planned
within the government and he will likely
uncover this the closer he gets to her
vic is based on the character victor
veep who in the comics was also a vault
plant as well unlike the show though
victor didn't have any powers and
victoria might end up becoming one of
the most powerful supers on earth if
she's able to get into the white house
in the comics volt manipulated the
political landscape so that vic the vip
became the president and we know that
this show will be playing up recent
events due to the rallies that we've
seen in the teasers this included a guy
who was dressed up as jason chanley who
stormed the capitol building in america
on january 6th looks like they're going
really political with it this season and
it might even be used as a way to usher
victoria into the white house i can see
this being what happens down the line
due to the comics and they had a scene
in which homelander ripped off vic's
head which would be ironic as she
exploded lots of people throughout
season 2. now in this new teaser it
seems like huey's working at the federal
bureau of superhuman affairs are looking
over everything i think this will
probably be how he learns about victoria
but it's a nice flip to have him in
charge blue power's gone to his head so
like the the power's gone to butcher
chapter
now he does seem to change as we get him
talking about butch's way after
realizing vort always wins if they play
by the rules
the gloves are off
i thought we could fight about the right
way but we can't it's all rigged we have
to do it your way we also see mother's
milk at the 10th birthday party for his
daughter jeanine it's seven themed and
we catch the deep amongst the lineup as
well later on we see mother's milk and
has stopped the violence t-shirt and
huge shout out to everyone on our last
video who pointed out that he always
wears hip-hop-related clothing and this
is a nod to krs1 as she is of course
back and her hair continues to fall out
this is actually riffing on the comics
in which jessica bradley also pulled her
hair out too when she was stressed
towards the end of the run she seems to
be banging the director i think that
come the end of the series she might be
completely bald as this seems to be a
recurring thing for her character at one
point homelander seems to push someone
off a building before he rides into the
rally and i think this is likely him
presenting that he's just stopped a
super villain when it was probably just
a member of the public now soldier boy
is the leader of a group called payback
who we got a movie poster for over the
weekend when the trailer date
announcement was released i'm gonna go
over this with the characters for the
next part of the video as it's probably
easier explaining them this way and
diving in and out of trailer shots this
contains all of the members including
soldier boy at the front we then have
black noir on the top left and just
below him is gunpowder gunpowder in the
comics was basically a punisher parody
who shot first and asked questions later
and we know that butcher will be
fighting him at some point in the season
when he's coming to grips with a
compound v flowing through his system
he's also based on judge dredd and the
comics had him looking a lot closer to
their character which sort of lines up
with the design he has here gunpowder is
probably going to be the first superstar
butcher kills and then he'll slowly work
his way up the chain we know from post
by eric kripke that the first episode
will be called payback and this will
likely focus on the group and gathering
them back together however payback of
course means getting revenge like i'll
be doing if you don't hit the thumbs up
on the video just just hit the thumbs up
you see the thumbs up and in the comics
stormfront was a major member of the
group but with her being turned into
anakin skywalker last season soldier boy
might want to get payback on the boys at
the top of the tnt twins who are going
to be parodies of the wonder twins from
dc comics those guys activate their
powers by touching hands much like how
the pair do here the next one seems like
it might be the ant-man and wasp parody
swatto that we got teases towards in the
first trailer when a guy literally
exploded out of another guy's butt i
think that was riffing on the whole
thanos butt thing that people were doing
for end game and i think it would be
hilarious if he did that in the show now
there might have actually been some
hints towards swado in other episodes of
the show if you like reaches which you
do cause you're here and that's why
we're doing theory time air time your
time
okay so when the boys season one and two
drop there were lots of fans that
noticed a weird fly popping up on the
screen inside i did a video and there's
a couple of ones on youtube discussing
them popping about nowhere i'd love it
if this was retroactively made to be
swat out and that he just been following
the boys since the beginning but that's
the end of your time your time your time
next is crimson countess who'll be
played by laurie holden she's basically
a skull at which character and she's as
chaotic as wonder is which i swear isn't
a pun however she's not really at the
level that wonder is now and after
multiverse of madness i think she might
actually be a good guy in comparison to
what warner does in that film oconus can
fire red orbs out of her hands in the
show but she can't really warp reality
otherwise she'd be pretty unstoppable
the last character is someone i'm a bit
unsure of but let me know below if you
know who this is now it does seem like
maeve might end up dying this season we
see her practicing with a sword at one
point and as we know she's exposing a
lot of things about homelander in the
comics she tried to kill the character
with his sword but it was revealed to be
a prop so it didn't work and he brutally
murdered her get lots of flashbacks of
that very memorable moment when i see
her practicing and either sheer homeland
is probably going to go down in the
season now the pop group that we see
appearing could be teenage kicks a team
in the comics that were basically a
parody of the teen titans a train was a
member of this group and starlight also
dated one of the team called drummer boy
according to the behind the scenes info
that we have on the show this will be
changed up slightly and will get her ex
supersonic appearing in the series who
will be a speedster that also rivals my
boy a train aka the guy who doesn't mind
running a train on your girl hey god
damn the puns are nice now they seem to
be teeny bob pop stars that bought
market to the kids and it looks like
they might even be a boy band which is a
nice twist on the comics i kind of
wonder if the bloney [ __ ] will also be a
part of them like he was in the source
material in the comics he was killed and
then because compound b basically fires
up your nervous system he came back as
one of the undead which they might do
with either him or lamplighter similar
to the source material now we also know
that the season will have the events of
herogasm playing out in the show this
was actually a limited six issue series
within the comics that was basically
just a sordid sex party for the soups
annually they'd kind of throw this event
that basically allowed characters to let
their hair down and have whatever their
heart desired bort would create a cover
story for the group where they'd say
they'd gone off will to fight
intergalactic threats but they'd really
just done what my wife does with the
milkman when they both go to butlins it
looks like the deep might even end up
being at something like this as he is
checking out the sea life nice
now lastly the big thing we need to talk
about is butcher getting powers the
compound b that he takes is green or as
the official one released by boris blue
making me think that this is a
counterfeit one produced on the black
market since the public found out about
the truth he shoots eye lasers similar
to homelander and now has super strength
he's pretty much becoming a reflection
of homelander and it's going to be
really interesting to see how they
handle his progression i think it'll
come down to either him killing
homelander or possibly ryan who we know
will be in this season his mother becky
of course died in the last one and he
seems angry that things played out the
way they did so he could be looking for
revenge might come down at him and belly
the latter of which stops him from
becoming the dark and twisted soups that
becky was worried about him turning into
ryan was handed off to mallory and the
cia but it looks like he's gonna come
back into it at some point now i want to
get into some comic spoilers so if you
don't want anything from the source
material ruined then i recommend that
you check out now please hit the thumbs
up button on your way out and also
subscribe for coverage on the show every
week okay punks so this is the real
heavy spoilers part of the show but in
the comics after homelander was defeated
butcher revealed his true plan and we
learned that he was actually also
somewhat of a villain he continued
killing supes and because the boys had
all taken compound v this included them
he murdered mother's milk frenchie and
also the female who in the comics is
basically the counterpod to kimiko billy
ended up going head-to-head with hughie
at the end of the book and the latter
one though it was clear but she kinda
let him do it billy's brother lenny was
always the person that kept him on the
straight and narrow but after his death
butcher became a wild card that's why he
ended up taking huey under his wing
because he viewed him as being similar
to his brother who'd always held him
back from going over the deep end but
you left huey alive until the very end
for this exact reason and he allowed
himself to be stopped by huey before he
could carry out his plan to kill old
soups that might be where the show is
going might not be but i thought i'd say
that for the spoiler part of the video
in case you didn't want to know anyway
that's the trailer and with this show
being less than three weeks away i
cannot wait to watch it this season
looks like it's going to be bringing
back all the gore political intrigue
satire and comedy the previous entries
have had and i can't wait to see it play
out gonna be a great season i think and
there's gonna be so much stuff from the
comics they can adapt to really knock
this out the park let me know your
comments below and just to let you know
we're running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of the
batman on the 15th of june all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
to like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the trailer if you pick the comments at
random on that day and the winners of
the last one on screen right now if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers you want some else to
watch them make sure you check out our
writing of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which will be
linked on screen right now we break down
the entire thing and it's definitely
worth checking out if you have any
questions over that movie without the
way thanks for sitting through the video
i mean paul i'll see you next time take
care peace